hello my name is tom felton from youtube
premiums news show origin today I shall
be answering some fan questions out of
his rather delightful looking Cup Emma
Watson revealed her first crush was she
who are filming the first two Harry
Potter films was the crush mutual let's
move on come on now it's money for this
now we've been very good friends for a
very long time
leaving the lap would you ever reprise
your role with Draco Malfoy of the
opportunity presented it of course
definitely what did you enjoy the most
about your time on set filming the flash
getting dancing lessons from Grant
Gustin he's a good mover and the groover
and a fun chat to be with so he was he
give me lessons I haven't danced since
his rather tragic what G to the role of
Logan in origin in which ways are you
similar to him well we look alike we
have the same colored eyes Logan and I
have very different different people I
think he comes from a rather broken
family with rather crap friends and Tom
is quite the opposite what drew me to it
was the sort of multinational aspect of
the show the fact that it kind of goes
around the globe in all 10 episodes and
Mika Watkins our fearless showrunner and
writer she was instrumental in getting
me on board not only is she a lovely
person she's also furiously talented did
you take anything from the Harry Potter
set technically no I'm not going to tell
you more cos I still want one of others
to hire me in the future the Harry
Potter movies starred so many great
adult actors what was the relationship
like year between you and the older cast
were you close with anyone in particular
not really as when I was a kid I had no
idea who any of these people were I just
had my mum telling me that Maggie Smith
was a huge actress and Richard Harris
was a legend the only one I really was
terrified of was Alan Rickman because I
knew him from Robin Hood so I was pretty
terrified of him it took me quite a lot
of courage just to say anything more
than good morning Alan to him cuz he was
pretty terrifying
I thought Gary Oldman was one of the
cleaners first because he was so
casually just walking around yeah so it
still not to tell me that he's playing
serious black but they were all lovely
Helena Bonham Carter was definitely one
of my favorites jason isaacs who plays
my dad I learned a lot from him he was
very sweet but honestly they were all
lovely so I'm very lucky for that what
was the most challenging aspect of
taking on the role
logan in origin well he's American for
starters so I had to sort of work on
that a little bit he's a petty drug
dealer so I had to do some petty drug
dealing just to get the character
honestly the most challenging thing was
probably being in Cape Town for seven
months not that it wasn't beautiful and
an amazing place to shoot but it's a
long time to spend away from friends and
family other than that it was all
swimmingly what is your first onset
memory from filming the Harry Potter
movies I don't know is the stuff a lot
chocolates and sweets inside the robe
and I remember they used to melt and
they get stuck in there and then they
shouted at me and they've got sweets
banned from set because of me what do
you think Julian Albert has been up to
since he left style as for England would
you return for another season if asked
yes absolutely
I think Julian Albert does deserve a
comeback episode at least what's he been
up to waffling around in England I
suppose yes I'm not even sure what the
excuse was that they gave for why Julian
Albert didn't return but he's bloody
busy in England by the sounds of things
you've released music in the past are
you planning on releasing more songs or
potentially an album yes I am I'm still
recording and still doubling and
battling with a few few tunes and I do
hope to make an EP at least or a short
album of some sort I'm not sure when or
how or why but I'm gonna do at some
point so thank you for your interest if
you could go back and film one Harry
Potter movie all over again which one
would it be and why bloody good
questions people enjoying these I don't
know really I mean I wouldn't change
anything although I'm sure eyeballs a
lot of it up when I was there maybe the
last one because it was the longest a
bit more time to soak it all in
well I would want to go back but also I
wouldn't want to damage anything further
than I already have
so maybe just the last one that'd be fun
does a text thread with you and the rest
of the Harry Potter cast exists is there
anyone who you keep in touch with the
most I think there is I think there is I
never answered it I think I got in
trouble with Emma once for not paying
any contribution to that but there is
we're all pretty natural phones to be
honest with you so I'm not sure how up
to date is well Matthew Lewis young
young Longbottom he lives around the
corner from me so I see him quite
regularly
Bonnie as Lopez Jenny she's around so we
are dogs have hung out a couple times
but we always see each other in one way
stable form and so yes it's always fun
to keep in touch with them what are you
hoping audiences take away from origin
well entertainment
for one I hope you have a bloody good
time watching it but also it does us I
just asked some really poignant
questions about what we're doing on this
planet and is there any hope for us on
another planet you took Pottermore
sorting quiz and we're sorted into
Gryffindor what would your hybrid house
be I'm definitely a sliver door I think
if that's the correct term also I don't
think that I'm actually Gryffindor I
tried to lie to the Sorting Hat by
overly going with sliver and answers
particularly dark and I think it knew so
yes my true house is yet to really be
decided what's your favorite
behind-the-scenes memory with Daniel
Radcliffe for shooting the Harry Potter
films crikey so many I don't know I
remember having Simpsons trivia battles
with him well in the middle of in
between doing Quidditch we used to ask
each other pot Simpsons questions which
he was much better at did Draco Malfoy
get the ending he thought he deserved in
Deathly Hallows absolutely not he should
have killed everyone and run off into
the sunset no of course it's perfect
Joe wrote some fabulous stories and I
dare not amend them at all thank you the
cup is empty thanks for your lovely
questions you actually much better than
most interviewers see you around
watch origin YouTube premium
[Music]